I'll say this for the separatist they're
tenacious how many times are we had to
chase them off this plan too many master
I guess they haven't learned their
lesson yet in factual location Geonosis
[ __ ]
give it up without a fight we're
approaching our target Master Sakura and
blow Koon will keep the bulk of androids
occupied while we make our assault you
ready for this ahsoka
it's crucial that we neutralize this
joint factory we can't have General
Grievous building actual reinforcements
boys often focus our money
you must more than this than just
innovation Perry
proceed with caution my friend our
forces are fighting with the many battle
droids protecting this factory complex
we must get in there but this battle has
just begun more enemy units are ahead
we come up the way we must advance
you cannot leave any of these
battledroids Stanley's well done now
move swiftly while we have the advantage
the data head has been secured by
general Grievous's battle droids
neutralize them I can use their
lightsabers to deflect certain attacks
when caught in a b-1 droids blaster fire
continuously block the attack to watch
the bolts reflect off your lightsaber
else is your Allah user to bring down
that gate
Revis has deployed his commander George
you what you colossal extroyer's have a
powerful attack that when they begin to
wind up an attack use your block
maneuver to reduce damage by Walker wins
again
you must find a way into the factory
complex in a dark road to the spider in
the arena
those doors are jammed use the horse to
open them
these battle droids must be defeated if
our mission is to succeed aid the clone
troopers in their fight
now this is the strength of a jet
good work